roxane cloutier a passé 25 ans de sa vie
dans un chou box vue de normanville dans
rosemont petite patrie
j'étais à l'école primaire j'adorais le
quartier j'ai vraiment envie que le tout
mais sauniére sont de petites patries au
décès de sa mère oksana hérité de la
maison elle et son conjoint veulent
aujourd'hui s'y installer pour élever
leurs futurs enfants
je vais faire ma famille ici avant mes
enfants ici de kayar mépris mark et moi
pour moi c'était vraiment à voir ma
famille dans le quartier où moi j'ai
vécu et grant hill tous les éléments qui
composent la maison c'est pas compliqué
le toit face à des infiltrations mais on
voit que c'était une maison qui était
d'un très très mauvais état après
inspection l'architecte du couple
conclut qu'il faut démolir la maison on
est passé devant comité de démolition en
mars 2010
et là où vit le comité d'émotion a été
en faveur une année mettant faveur de
notre projet donc oui on avait le ok on
pouvait aller de l'avant leur projet
initial une unifamiliale de deux étages
ressemble à ce qui est construit juste
en face de chez eux après des rencontres
avec l'arrondissement le couple est sous
l'impression que la construction de leur
maison n'est plus qu'une formalité sauf
que dans rosemont la petite patrie la
transformation des choux box est un
sujet hautement sensible dans le passé
plusieurs de ces petites maisons ont été
remplacés par des bâtiments de deux
étages ou encore par des condos échoue
boxe dans heureusement il en reste
environ 560 dès que le projet de
démolition du show box de roxane et
rendu public des groupes s'organisent
sur les réseaux sociaux certains
s'opposent à la démolition
on juge primordial d'en préserver la
façade et surtout son joli couronnement
sauver cette maison qui le méritent
grandement des opposants laisse même
entendre que la maison est menacé par le
promoteur qui souhaite en faire des
condos
le couple est renversé par une telle
levée de boucliers
on s'attendait pas à ça en fait on se
concerte pas comme étant des méchants
tant que terre neuve suivi procédure
c'est vraiment une panière public le 7
mai la décision finale est rendu le
conseil d'arrondissement reconnaît que
dans l'état actuel la chaux box doit
être démoli mais les élus drews mans
estime qu'il faut aussi protéger la
façade
c'est exactement ce qu'on a demandé dans
le corps du mail m
chaque façade le projet initial du coupé
donc rejeter pour construire leur maison
l'arrondissement les oblige à refaire la
façade du premier tel quel
roxane et ken lee craint que cette
obligation fasse grimper
significativement la facture de
maçonnerie mais tu es 32 e mail pour une
petite fanfare comme sauter c'est
vraiment cher en plus ils ont un rapport
d'expert qui leur déconseille de
reproduire le même jeu de briques
une façon de faire qui selon l'expert
multiplie les risques d'infiltration
d'eau 80 mâ sans qu'il faille faire
nominer
il faut que ça soit bien fait pour la
conseillère responsable du dossier c'est
le prix à payer pour préserver cet
héritage du passé pour préserver le
patrimoine résidentiel
il faut investir dedans blanc ghost et
ajoute qu'à l'avenir pour ce qui est des
choux boxe les règles seront plus clair
dans ce dossier la nuit énormément de
voiliers énormément de difficultés de
tractations ça joue la corde
on a beaucoup appris de ce colloque puis
c'est justement pour empêcher ces
longues heures là ces difficultés là ton
adopte les changements de règlement mais
le règlement proposé par
l'arrondissement pour protéger les choux
box soulève l'inquiétude de plusieurs
propriétaires plus d'une centaine sont
venus exprimer leurs craintes lors d'une
récente séance d'information guillaume
pas de possibilité d'aller une contested
demande une révision en tête
alors on voit qu'il ya des terrains
on a été comme servi d'exemple un acteur
ce qui frustre d'autant plus le couple
sait qu'à quelques mètres de chez eux
l'arrondissement a permis la
construction d'une tour à condos sur un
ancien bâtiment industriel
c'est un peu l'aspect qui nous fâche et
émotionnellement à l'arrondissement on
nous dit qu'un tel projet de condos
n'arrivera plus mais pour le couple la
hauteur de l'édifice
leur bloc maintenant soleil
[Musique]